[Music]
whether we like it or not
we are immersed essentially in a society
nationally and internationally that's
driven by technology that's driven by
devices and processes communication
linkages transportation household
appliances and attainment capability and
what-have-you which is all dominated by
technology and design underlies all of
that if you don't design a product as
competitive you lose that market
[Music]
design is the ultimate bit of
engineering everything else really
serves design but when you ask yourself
what is everybody doing what they are
doing for in the modern world I mean we
are not living in trees plucking
coconuts and bananas off the trees and
eating them we're doing all kinds of
other things and why are we doing those
because of design it's the only reason
its technologies is just a complete
collection of the output of designers
design is the process of really solving
a problem it's not the process of
writing about the solution to a problem
it's not just the process of dreaming
about the solution to a problem design
is the process that happens when someone
tells you that you have to do it a
design engineer takes enormous pleasure
in producing designs which either on
paper or preferably in the hardware that
work you get a fan enormous thrill from
putting something together that works
well design is improving the
relationship between people and
technology considering all the criteria
of aesthetics
liability and error both human and
machine and of course cost and one has
to be engaged in the design process in
the innovation process in the creation
process whether one's total lifespan
children infants should be encouraged to
design things design is also a the most
important element in the achievement of
progress over the last decade
microprocessor technology has touched
off a revolution in design practice in
the near future design engineers will
use powerful desktop computers with
interactive graphics capabilities
increasingly engineers are using micro
processors as basic building blocks in
products which are intelligent hybrids
of mechanical and electrical components
today educators must meet the challenge
of teaching students how to design this
new generation of intelligent products
as well as how to take advantage of
these powerful new design tools to
stimulate creative thinking and insight
[Applause]
design courses at MIT progressed through
three levels of sophistication first in
an undergraduate course students use a
given kit of materials to solve a
well-defined problem in a design contest
here the purpose is to design a device
to put a cylinder in the hole before the
opponent can second in a senior-level
course students must come up with a
creative and economical solution to more
realistic problems this student designed
a sturdy cost-effective oil exploration
platform for the iceberg plagues waters
of the Beaufort Sea awful a planning to
do is just by carrier some kind of big
ship it's roughly 200 metres by 30
metres wide we're gonna sail it up there
we're gonna buy it used which means that
the price is quite low I'll sail it up
there and sink it in the ocean
and use the decks as a platform you know
whatever it is you're doing as a
designer you can't it's like if we just
had equations pumped into us you know
for four years straight and we went out
and had a problem we wouldn't know where
to begin but what we learned to do in
design is how to approach it and what
kinds of things have to go into doing
some sort of analysis so that you can do
as design that will actually you know
work this way you going off in a
different direction if you you don't
have to go all the way back and start
something else you can keep going and if
you get a different right answer there
you get a chance to use your creativity
it's really not too creative just
solving problems from a book but it's
very interesting to try and figure out
how to solve a problem by yourself so
now we're interesting - really it's it's
fun it's it was fun
[Music]
third the graduate level course gives
students experience in solving real
problems submitted by industrial
sponsors famous define the problems
analyzed propose a solution build it and
make it work the problem was to design a
system for an office tabletop copy
machine that would take a stack of paper
and feed it one sheet at a time to the
rest of the machine now obviously there
are a lot of systems like this existing
and the goal here was to make one that
we've had a better price performance
aspect than any in existence today and
specifically the performance had to be
fewer than 500 errors per million sheets
bad and the price had to be kept below
fifty dollars in a production form and
it's taught me a lot to think of
creative things and how to really get
things done not just talk about getting
done or it's one thing to draw out how
something is going to work but when he
actually comes to making it it's never
gonna work right the first time
throughout all levels of design
education interaction between student
and teacher is crucial to the
educational process okay what's gonna
happen when it doesn't work
how are you gonna know it right now yeah
I mean I suspect you could well work
nine times out of ten but that tenth
time you're going to have
banks this thing back up in the hangar
without having cutaway
Yeah right that's an issue and I think
unless you believe that it's going to
work
you're gonna have to get some thought to
how you know
in the computer aided design laboratory
we're conducting research in three major
areas one the construction of
three-dimensional solid models through
orthographic projections to the
modification of geometric models through
variational geometry and three the
automatic scaling of Assemblies of
components geometric models are
computer-based representations of
geometry they're used extensively in
industry to
performed rafting analysis programming
of NC machine tools and other related
functions unfortunately the most common
medium for describing the geometry
historically has been 2-dimensional
orthographic projections such as shown
here this program that we're developing
in this area's function is to take
two-dimensional orthographic projections
so and try to reconstruct the
three-dimensional solid which they
depict
this program was developed to provide a
more flexible and more natural means for
modifying geometry because geometry is
changed very often in the course of
production from the time that designer
first conceives of a desire geometry to
the time it's manufactured itself third
many times and we're attempting here to
provide a very natural flexible way of
changing geometry the third area of
research involves the automatic scaling
of Assemblies of components it is an
attempt to develop procedures whereby
the process of design can be stored in
addition to the result of the design
process I tell you what I mean every
dimension is shown here as a rule a
decision rule that indicates how that
dimension was chosen so that as is often
the case when the boss comes in later
and says I have to change the basic
assumptions on which your original
design was performed such as changing
the power of this transmission from 1 to
3 kilowatts in future you'll be able to
simply push a button and produce
new scaled geometry
these and other research activities
pretty clearly indicate that the design
profession is undergoing some pretty
rapid and radical technological change
right now and we as an educational
institution have an obligation to
provide our students with an education
that will prepare them to both use this
technology and to develop the design
tools and neither you or I can even
conceive of right now
[Music]
Golden Gate Bridge doesn't sway in a
hurricane and destroy itself it seems to
work in all circumstances it works very
well
it also looks fantastic be beautiful and
if I had designed the Golden Gate Bridge
I'd buy myself a little bit of man and
put a cottage on and just live there
look out the window
[Music]